power shortages blackouts damaged
infrastructure the u.s electrical grid
is under strain
large sustained outages have happened
with increasing frequency in the us over
the past two decades according to a wall
street journal review of federal data
driven largely by weather-related
problems weather events are becoming
more frequent and extreme so that's a
real challenge for the system
and weather events the last few summers
have set records let's look back to get
an idea of how hotter drier and more
turbulent weather this summer could
affect the grid
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration or noaa says this
hurricane season will probably be above
normal last year hurricane ida showed
how a category 4 hurricane the second
highest classification could strain the
electrical grid winds ripping apart
buildings sending this roof crashing
into a power pole snapping it in half
hurricane ida made landfall in louisiana
knocking out some parts of the
electrical grid it could be weeks before
the mangled shredded power grid is
restored and leaving more than 900
thousand people in the state without
power
then it hit the northeast pico an
electric and natural gas utility based
in philadelphia said flooding engulfed
three electrical substations forcing two
to go offline
ida left more than sixty thousand in
pennsylvania without power more than
forty thousand in new jersey and twenty
two thousand in new york were also in
the dark
it just goes to show the the risk
that you know the infrastructure can
face when you have an extreme weather
event like that
even more so if that event is stronger
as a result of a change in climate and
repairing hurricane damaged power and
transmission equipment and
infrastructure takes time the turnaround
time to bring the grid back can be
really damaging if your food can't be
preserved it can spoil which is a
problem because you can go hungry or it
has a sort of a medical risk if the food
is dangerous you also can't use
electricity to treat your water if you
don't have electricity and we use
electricity to make our water safe to
drink so if you don't have food or water
that's safe to consume that's a real
threat to human health
it can take around two weeks to get
customers reconnected in some
circumstances according to professor
weber
some local utility providers like
entergy in new orleans and conned in new
york have implemented upgrades
but a recent assessment by the american
society of civil engineers estimates
that the u.s electrical grid faces a
funding gap expected to grow to 197
billion dollars by 2029.
con ed said this year that in light of
more frequent and destructive storms it
will invest in placing overhead electric
cables and other equipment underground
to prevent outages during severe storms
but hurricanes aren't the only weather
event that can stress the power grid
increased temperatures all over the
country cause electrical grid strain and
damage which can lead to blackouts
it makes it harder to cool your house
it's harder to let your power plant take
it easy for a little bit to recover so
they're more at risk of failure it's
just a real challenge to the whole
system
that happened last year in the pacific
northwest when heat hit the region the
all-time record heat is crippling the
pacific northwest an area most residents
live without air conditioning in spokane
washington heat forced the local
electric utility to turn off substation
transformers which can't function at
temperatures higher than 104 degrees the
black house lasted for a couple of days
they turned off the equipment so that it
wouldn't be severely damaged that's not
the only problem high heat caused grids
were also strained by air conditioning
use
about 44 of homes in the seattle area
and 79 of homes in the portland area
have some form of air conditioning
according to the census bureau if you
have an air conditioner and all your
neighbors in their houses if we all turn
our air conditioners on the same time
this creates a lot of demand about half
of the peak demand in a hot day is just
our air conditioners at our homes not
including all the other ways we use
electricity
this year in mid-june high temperatures
enveloped a third of the u.s population
in seattle's public electric utility has
already issued a heat advisory this year
avista one of the electric utilities
covering the area said they have
invested in additional infrastructure
planning after last year's heat wave
exposed differences in electrical use
since the pandemic substation upgrades
that were in progress last summer
continued this year they don't
anticipate having to proactively turn
power off this summer as a result of the
heat
another contributor to blackouts is a
lack of hydroelectric power caused by
droughts hydroelectric power makes up
about seven percent of the u.s
electrical mix it made up 16 of
california's in 2019
hydro is pretty constrained this summer
because the west has been in a period of
severe drought for a long time and as
reservoirs
lose capacity you know it reduces the it
reaches hydroelectric capacity
hydroelectric power is produced when
dams channel the immense pressure
created by a body of water they're
blocking into turbines which generate
electricity the north american electric
reliability corporation said this summer
could potentially have lower than
average output from hydro generators
those served by locations like the
hoover dam one of the nation's largest
hydroelectric facilities may have
already felt strained from shortages the
hoover dam can provide enough power for
about 1.3 million people and the dam has
a large capacity it's about the same as
two nuclear power plants and so losing
two nuclear power plants worth of
generating capacity that's a real strain
on the region every foot of water lost
in lake mead the reservoir feeding the
dam equates to about six fewer megawatts
of power generated which roughly
translates to the power consumed by 800
homes since last june the lake has lost
around 25 feet of water if lake mead
falls below 950 feet of water the dam
shuts down and no electricity is created
at the end of june water levels were
around 100 feet from the cut-off
some states are looking to supplement
the potential decrease in power
california governor gavin newsom
included an additional 9.5 billion
dollars in a may 2022 budget proposal to
account for drought over the next four
years
there's a collective understanding that
utilities across the board are working
to upgrade their infrastructure to
account for more extreme weather the
events even last summer and the threat
of more events this summer has
made that need very clear
scheduled upgrades fueled in part by
these weather events could lead average
residential electrical bills to increase
between 2.5 and 3 percent a year for the
next several years
[Music]